as usual the theme of this has been
taking crafts that you were already
familiar with it and they transforming
them in some way applying some kind of
function that does something that alters
the behavior of that graph right and it
doesn't make it something unrecognizable
this clearly a relationship but the
kinds of relationships are well they're
not immediately obvious okay now we've
already focused on our more different
ways of trading what kinds of ways to be
doing the transfer graphs already you
can uh you can take to grass and you can
add them together right which of course
it prizes subtraction you can also take
two maps and rather than adding or
subtracting you can multiply right which
therefore also applies to measures okay
so that's what you've got to computed so
you put the ten you're combining them in
some way that's why I was calling them
composite functions now just to finish
out we're gonna look at grass raised to
a power I'm gonna focus on three powers
in particular namely two as you can see
from this example three and a half which
is basically well it's a square root
yeah there are loads of other powers in
between obviously that you can look at
but if you nail the back of your two
three and a half you have all the tools
you need to look at any other power you
like so here's where we're going to
start I've got my sine x on there you've
probably got a decent one there already
as you've already noticed all that
arguments here visuals so the bigger you
and more accurate you make your original
graph the better you'll be able to make
some arguments about this guy okay all
right now just like before a crucial
piece of understanding what's going on
is to think about ordnance think about
ordnance so for instance the range of
sine X the range how low can I go to
combine negative 1 to 1
yes now the reason why that's important
is because when I square negative 1 or 1
I know exactly what's gonna happen to
those orbits right the square of 1 of
course is 1 and the square of negative 1
is I also 1 not the square root
we're just as good see actually can I
just say and um just wait until we get
into um it's a Knicks yeah there's a
hopping speech this pointless but one of
the hottest things that extension to
students in generally cannot is that
you're like you're doing so much stuff
you're like what which what is it like I
heard I know too many things so you need
to organize that my past get it get it
otherwise you'll be in trouble and your
computer self whether it's okay what a
negative one those are easy audits to
look out for what other easy auditors
are there all the routes right
everywhere I get x intercept the
ordinate is zero so the square of 0 is 0
some can you just kind of hang up okay
now have a look at this um you notice
all of my X's on it
they don't do the whole thing but there
are enough to see that applying the
logic to what you were you know just
squares right everything in my new graph
that I'm going to drill soon
everything's gonna be above the axis
well it will just touch right what is
that
yeah the smallest square number can be
at least where we read um we're in the
real world right thanks the smallest
that this window can be is 0 you cannot
get a negative number out of that okay
so whenever you have a graph and it's
being squared therefore you know okay
I'm up here in this region right that's
the first theaters then the second
theater this is a little bit harder okay
what's going to happen between here and
here
how is it going to get there for
instance you know we kind of look at
asymptotes we say oh okay I'm gonna
graph entering that and then I've like
adjusted it in some way like multiplied
or divided it by something sometimes
you'll be above that and then sometimes
you'll be below even if you're still
approaching the same asymptote so here
when I look at the sine x I posed the
question to you when I square it am I
going should be just above the side okay
or just below and importantly how do you
know what do you reckon that's ordinary
Jade was just
like there will be only place as a
fraction which is lower that one there
are fractions very very good okay in
case you didn't catch that right I'm
gonna rub this off in a second because
it's gonna make my diagram too busy but
think about again think about the
ordinance you see could be saying this
yet it's it's the crucial tool right
think about all these ordinates in here
I'm just going to put some vertical ones
now the weights of excuse me thank you
the length of all of these lines right
they're all between 91 degree with that
so they're these fractions okay what
were their proper fractions man now if
you square a number that's like saying
you know that'll be a half maybe right
when you square a half is it going to
get taller or shorter and they're just
gonna get short on it's gonna be half of
a half which is a quarter you know even
another like this maybe nine tenths
might be that link when you square that
and that's what I'm doing to all of the
Ottomans again it's gonna get smaller
9/10 would become eighty-one hundredths
right which is close to a Oh ten cents
again lower right so therefore
everywhere in here I'm Laura do you
agree with that okay now therefore I
know I'm gonna be in this region but
then the final question is well in that
region how am i behavior what am I
actually going to do right let me ask
you this okay you've noticed there's a
coup cavity to this right it's concave
down to do with that how can I get to
from here to here keeping in mind this
concavity right how am I gonna get from
here to here without crossing over
because you've told me right all of
these they're proper fractions to win a
square him I've got to stay underneath
right so I can't possibly go above right
so how am I gonna get there I'm gonna do
it
now you've got some choices like I mean
I could kind of try to do like a
straight line like that or I could try
to just underneath but before I draw
that I want you to notice I have a
stationary point here right you remember
when we were multiplying functions
before we're doing multiplication and
division okay
and this is what I've got is I'm
multiplying a function by itself sine X
and sine X and they both have a
stationary point there right
they both leveling off and if i zoom it
really really far
I get that horizontal one because that's
what that station is what it looks like
at high magnification okay so if I got a
stationary point and I'm multiplying it
by another stationary point what do you
expect the product averse to be it's
also gonna be my stationary point okay
now if I'm stationary there but I've got
to come underneath right then clearly
I've got to drop down like this do you
see that like I've got a spare any I've
got a stander need to sign X right so on
horizontal V stationary point and then I
drop down okay well I can't keep doing
this right I can't stay on my present
course and still get to here do you see
that like I had to be more calm came
down I had to be decreasing faster go in
this direction but if I keep on doing
this course I'm just gonna I'm never
gonna get to there right so I've got an
increase here but I've gotta slow back
down to get to here right like this
there has to be a change in concavity do
you see that do you see how I argued
that if I do it I'm not gonna make it to
that point okay so there's actually a
point of inflection here like I said
before once we learn the calculus of
trigonometric functions will reenter
differentiate and then differentiate
again and we will find BAM right in
there put anything okay but I'm making a
visual argument it's not as strong it's
good enough for me okay now that was the
hard part that was all the work now that
I've got this piece in here I'm sure
now that I've got that shape in there
everything else in the sine curve and
the sine X sine squared X curve is going
to follow that thing right because you
see from here to here I've got a shape
but from and let's let's do some numbers
here right from 90 degrees to 180
degrees of doing the same thing in
Reverse to see that
so therefore when I square I'm gonna get
the same thing in Reverse
okay now lastly down here this is the
same shape as this but just underneath
what difference does that make when I
swear no difference because the sign
which is the only difference here it
gets lost that information is lost more
squares okay
so therefore the shape I'm going to get
over here is an exact copy of this guy
so I'm going to get this but ah and
there it's a bit lopsided but you get
the idea there is my sine squared X term
interesting way it's periodic every 180
degrees rather than every 360 okay but
that's it that's it
any questions on that right so what I
want you to note is a couple of things
number one just what we're talking about
even sign this is like our summary and
conclusion okay if I raise to the power
of two or four or six or eight you're
always going to get an even number of
those right so even if there's a
negative you'll have like two negative
signs multiplying or four or six or
eight negative signs and they'll all
cancel right so therefore I conclude
even powers right they eliminate outside
sign and I should say
that exhibit sign with a G right
positive negative that information gets
lost as soon as you square okay they
learn it's a and in addition to this
right how would you describe this
behavior in here it's increasing but you
notice it's increasing faster at a
certain point when this ever gets to
okay so this kind of like a more extreme
behavior and we're going to look this
when we have a look at sine cubed M